I went to a hand surgeon to check out my finger wrist pain. X-rays showed nothing wrong with my bones.
He suggested a steroid injection in my wrist for dequeuravane symptoms. So dequeuravane's
syndrome, it's called a syndrome, is when you have pain in your wrist or hands
and that was named by a maybe an orthopedic surgeon back in the 1800s or something like that.
And now the medical field will treat it with just a steroid injection.
And you said, I want to talk to you first. So I know. So this dequeuravane's syndrome is just that.
So whenever it's not a disease, it's a syndrome. What's a syndrome? It's a collection of symptoms
that we have no idea why it's there. Okay, so again, you know, you're trying to ask why, right?
Now it was the right thing to do for them to take an X-ray because at least they're trying,
they're asking, why is there is there inflammation, you know, showing at the in the tendons,
is there a arthritic sparring or decreased joint space early degenerative changes that could be
causing this. And the answer was, no, there wasn't any orthopedic things. Well, then we'll just call it
the syndrome hand in wrist pain. And then we look up in Merck manual computer Merck manual,
no, and it says to give a steroid injection. Well, get that's, you know, you stopped asking why? So
you sometimes when something comes up, you look at the person's history and you say, could anything that
has changed since these symptoms started to appear be responsible for it. And we talked about this
already. We talked to Dr. Jan about this. And she said the aroma taste inhibitors can cause this.
And that is true. And then I told you that it's most likely because of the oral chemo drugs.
And I would still suggest because you've been off the oral mutation inhibitors and the pain
hasn't blown away, that it's more likely to do, be due to the oral chemo drugs. Because chemo drugs can
cause what is called hand in foot syndrome, which is exactly what you have. So and again, that's a
syndrome. We need the person just has pain. And it's the chemo drugs that have, have irritated the
joint capsules. And it can cause a secondary inflammatory arthritis that is not necessarily
present visibly on an x-ray or CTs get or MRI. So understand, take a step back a little bit.
When you have inflammation in a joint, pain in a joint, you ask that question, why do I have arthritis?
Now arthritis is arthritis, arthritis, inflammation, inflammation in the joint. But it is a disease.
So there's two different types of arthritic disease. So there's two different types of arthritis.
One is in degenerative arthritis, meaning that I hurt my knee in college, playing football,
and it's progressively, I've been able to limit it, but it's progressively getting worse.
And now I take an x-ray and my doctor said, boy, you have a really a decreased joint capsule,
joint space. In the right knee, compared to the left knee, you have some degenerative arthritis
taking place. The second type of arthritis is an inflammatory arthritis. That's your
psorianic arthritis, your rheumatoid arthritis, your, your, your echelocene spondylitis type diseases.
Those are inflammatory diseases which are often autoabute. So you have antibodies that have been
developed against the joint capsule. And that's causing inflammation and that's what's causing the
pain. Now inflammatory arthritis that are autoabute like this will can eventually lead to
fine deeds on x-ray. That's at a, as the disease progresses. Now what can cause these? Well,
heavy metals that irritate the joint capsule that cause your immune system to cause,
make antibodies to the joint capsule can cause that. Chemicals, poisons like chemotherapy drugs
that settle in the joint capsules. Remember because in the periphery, the hands and the feet,
you have less blood circulation and therefore less apt to detoxify poisons that are circulating
through your body and they're going to be more apt to settle in peripheral nerves causing
nerve damage and nerve issues or in the joint capsules causing inflammatory response and symptoms
that are have been termed hand in foot disease due to chemotherapy. So post chemotherapy patients
can get them and it has to do with the, with the chemical settling in the joint capsule causing
an inflammatory state. Long-term can cause an inflammatory arthritis and therefore seen on x-ray
maybe one to two years later as the disease progresses. So how do you treat that?
You treat it by detoxifying the chemo drugs as best you possibly can. Well, this person who
asked the question is already on a full bunch of keylators and binders and all this kind of stuff.
You can, you know, take more of that. You need to just try to, you know, get that out of the tissue,
you know, try to use the sawdust. You know, use hot water baths in your hands. Try to get
circulation. It's all in your hands. So your feet, you do it in both spots. Try to get more
circulation. Try to get that pumping through there as best you can. Can there be... Okay, my pain is
so bad. Can I use a drum? Can I use a steroid? Well, yeah, you can. A steroid will decrease the
inflammation. You can't break that inflammatory cycle a little bit. There can be benefits
and not against using drugs if you're understanding what the cause of this is and you're trying to treat,
trying to treat the cause at the same time. So using a medication to try to break that cycle,
no, since just suffering, you know, God has given us medication to help us prevent it. It's
going to be silly to, you know, you're not a greatest or something. Of course, you can use
medication to do that. Is it bad though? That's the question. Is it dangerous as a cancer patient to
use a steroid? Let's stop right there. Is it bad for a cancer patient to use a steroid?
It depends. So it's very common, a person with brain cancer, to be put on a steroid because the
inflammation of the brain can be very dangerous because you only have so much space for that cancer
to, or inflammation to expand. And then you could damage your old tissue. So it's important to be on
a steroid if you have a brain tumor. But if you have pain, let's say you're pain in your spine
because of spinal tassysis and you're going out an oral steroid that can decrease the pain if
that's the only thing you can do. But the negatives of an oral steroid is that you are going to have
some immune suppression. That's the negatives of an oral steroid. Do steroid injections cause the
same thing. So I think this person is asking the question because she's smart enough to know that
oral steroids do decrease the immune response. And not a good thing to be on long term, especially
high dose, low dose, not quite so much. But an oral, this is not an oral steroid injection. So a
steroid injection is going to be a higher dose right to that area. And of course you're going to absorb
it through the rest of the tissue and it's going to circulate through the bloodstream. So you're
going to have some systemic effects of it. But it should dissipate pretty quickly since you're only
getting one injection and you're not, you know, taking it out a daily basis. So I wouldn't be opposed
to it if, you know, if your pain is at a point where gosh, I got to do something about this is
crazy. I'm not opposed to doing that. But if, but also I would exhaust other things too. There's
different creams that a person could try come free cream. Some collendular cream might be helpful.
Some artica creams, taking artica might be helpful. I would try to exhaust those before I did that. But
if my pain was like driving me crazy, I'd say I don't think this is going to be a hindrance to
the cancer by doing a steroid injection. Typically, you're only going to do one maximum two kidney
points. Get this. The surgeon said it's not, it's not certain the drugs had anything to do with it.
But it's too much of a coincidence for me. Yeah, you kind of got to, you know, you're thinking for
yourself. And it's like, let's all start it when, you know, it's a time. And it's no, it's a,
you know, the drugs that they give you are known to cause this. So for them to say that
a little silly. But it's too much. He said that people with diabetes and hypothyroid are prone,
more prone to this. I would say I'd give person, if person does have, you know, uncontrolled diabetes,
yeah, they can be prone to inflammatory issues in their body. Hypothyroid, are you prone to
symptoms like this? No, that's that's that's that's not true. And just because your TSH has been
higher than usual is here. It doesn't mean that you're in a hypothyroid state. You need to look at